dozens of people including children who
have been injured in Ukraine after a
series of overnight Russian missile
strikes most of them are in pavlojad
east of nipro the Region's Governor says
it sparked a large fire in the city's
Industrial Area apartment blocks schools
and shops have been destroyed in Kiev
air defense systems could be seen
intercepting missiles and Air Raid
Sirens rying across the country for
three hours we're going to go live now
to Charles Stratford who's in Key Forest
there has been a lot of speculation
about a major push at some point by
Ukraine this seems to be an
intensification in the attacks as well
that's right Rob certainly it's safe to
say that there has been an increase in
the frequency of these attacks and an
increase in in how intense they are over
the last few days
Kiev officials here are saying that of
the 18 missiles that Russia launched 15
were intercepted but a lot of attention
being paid as you mentioned to the town
of pavlograd that is to the east of
danipro in the east of the country some
dramatic pictures of an explosion having
happened interestingly so individual
plumes of smoke
um shooting up to the sky suggesting
possibly weapons or ammunition exploding
there's been no official comment from
the ukrainians as to
um whether this was a weapons Depot that
is you know that's not unusual they do
not comment on those sorts of things
they're saying that this was some sort
of industrial Enterprise but uh yeah
um at least 19 apartment buildings
damaged 25 private homes around 25
people injured in these attacks and of
course as you mentioned they come as we
expect any time now for this so-called
Ukrainian counter-offensive we know that
there have been tens of thousands of
Ukrainian troops that have been flooding
into the east of the country and that
area pavlograd is one would imagine one
of the main supply routes
so yeah it is uh not surprising but it
is safe to say that these attacks are
now increasing in intensity and
frequency as we get closer to this
expected Ukrainian counter-offensive
Charles Trafford and Keith Charles thank
you